good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp-2406
object class
safe
special containment procedures
provisional site 31 has been built
around
scp-2406 and is to maintain the facade
of a kazakhstani military facility type
a hazmat suits are mandatory when
working directly with scp-2406
as is decontamination upon exit a
security perimeter of armed guards is to
remain in place at all times in order to
prevent unauthorized access direct
interaction with scp-2406-1
requires authorization by site command
description
scp-2406
is a mechanical automaton 93 meters in
height and weighing approximately 210
tons research indicates that
scp-2406 was not sentient and required
at least six operators to properly
function it is hypothesized that
scp-2406 was piloted by a 160 different
valves and levers within its interior
limbs were controlled through the
application of pneumatics hydraulics and
clockwork and powered by a nuclear
reactor located within the torso
scp-2406 was discovered on august 7 1985
in the uralcom desert formerly the
eastern basin of the aral sea during an
effort to track the unusually high
levels of radiation in the water
initially contained by gru division p
scp-2406 would be transferred into
foundation custody following the
collapse of the soviet union despite the
location of its recovery
scp-2406 is believed to have been built
somewhere in the aegon sea
most of scp-24s is composed of an alloy
consisting of 75 to 80 percent copper 15
to 20 zinc and smaller percentages of
nickel lead and iron the admixture
responsible for its bronze appearance
inscribed upon the posterior of the
exterior torso is the aegon numeral for
nine suggesting that scp-2406
may not be an entirely unique
construction however as of to date it
remains the only of its kind known to
the foundation the anterior and exterior
torso is engraved with a stylized hammer
and anvil
the right arm was equipped with a nozzle
attached to a 20 800 liter tank although
the tank was discovered empty chemical
testing revealed pine resin naphtha
quick lime calcium phosphide and sulfur
within its interior the left arm appears
to have been torn from scp-2406
and was not initially recovered with
scp-2406
see addendum for details
human skeletal remains six in number
have been removed from the interior of
scp-2406
with radiocarbon dating placing their
deaths at cal 1200 to 100 bce all were
found to be attired in armor that while
roughly mycenaean in design is composed
of material never used in ancient
warfare a leading copper alloy with an
inner lining composed of asbestos fabric
the helmet would have completely covered
the head with a green tinted glass visor
over the face tubes constructed from
gold intestines fed outside air directly
into the mouths of the pilots valve 136
would have caused a momentary release of
water into these tubes allowing those
within to remain hydrated while
operating
scp-2406 a similar system of tubes
attached at the crotch and were
presumably used in the expulsion of
urine
scp-2406 is currently disabled but could
hypothetically be repaired and displays
extensive evidence of combat related
damage the head torso and left leg were
discovered impaled by organic spines
these spines appear superficially
kitenous and despite showing strong
structural similarities to coral
contained human dna it is believed that
these objects functioned as projectiles
employed by an unidentified anomalous
organism indentations around the torso
are suggestive of constriction by a
large flexible and prehensile appendage
originally thought to be caused by
natural corrosion
scp-2406's outer layer was damaged by a
strong acidic substance likely
associated with the previously
unidentified anomalous organism
physical evidence suggests that the
reactor core melted through the
posterior torso penetrating the earth
and continues to burn at more than 12
000 degrees celsius it is estimated to
be presently located at approximately
820 meters beneath the surface the
reactor when intact has been
hypothesized to have functioned in a
similar manner to natural nuclear
fission reactors deviating significantly
from modern designs it is possible that
the creators of scp-24
were aware of such phenomena and
attempted to mimic the process
several scrolls were recovered from a
water-tight cylinder within
scp-2406 most appear to be of a
religious nature and associated with the
followers of mccain the historical
precursor to the modern church of the
broken god the scrolls are written in a
unique script derived from mycenaean
greek it required 10 years of research
for foundation linguists to decipher
this system of writing these documents
included a variation of the book of
pieces chapter 12.
[Music]
scroll one
the colossi were constructed in her
schema the colossi were constructed to
defend the enemy grand carcassed ion
betrayer of men destroyer of progress
sorcerer king of attitum a desolate
domain a failed and fallen creation
built with the bodies of dead gods upon
a throne of black ambition the enemy
plots
the enemy is not a priest
they are a merchant and they have sold
the world the colossi were constructed
in her schema the colossi were
constructed to defend
the profane tools must be broken drink
deep the silver blood of mccain
may her sacrifice not be in vain
scroll two
this is the final testament of matriarch
you praxia legate's faithful servant of
mccain i am not a warrior but all
warriors are dead breaking themselves
upon the enemy's host the enemy has set
their plan into motion the sorcery king
surrounds himself with corpses to fight
is to grow his legions egypt retreats
from the world the hittites have fallen
into chaos the conspirators of crete
have sacrificed their own the aegian has
fallen into barbarism the city of a
thousand pillars is forever lost has
always been lost even the deva grow
desperate with the enemy at their border
the center collapses kingdoms crumble
the damage is done the light of reason
flickers but mccain sacrificed herself
so that we might be free we refuse to
return to that darkness we would rather
die but the siege at garros was won
we must strike while the metal is hot
and thus we march for kythera at the end
of all things we have crossed the wine
dark sea
we have seen villages ravaged by the red
death we have seen the dead the dying
and the deathless we cast the accursed
to holy flame we enter his desolate
domain and in our left hand we carry our
answer we cannot undo what has been done
but we can delay the psychic dawn
addendum
on december 12 1998 the left arm of
scp-2406 was uncovered 32 kilometers
from its body evidence of impact suggest
the object had been hurled to its
location shortly after being severed
from
scp-2406's torso the arm is equipped
with what has since been hypothesized to
be a weapon of non-terrestrial origins
and anomalous manufacture design and
capabilities due to its singular nature
when compared to the rest of scp-2006
this weapon has been separately
classified as scp-2406-1
the actual purpose of
scp-2406-1 is unknown the apparatus so
foreign is to render it beyond current
foundation knowledge scp-2406-1
possibly due to damage warps space-time
in its vicinity cat counters have
registered the object at a difference of
30 humes in relation to its surrounding
environment despite this there has been
no observable effect on reality
it has been hypothesized that the use of
scp-2406-1 would cause considerable
damage to local reality it remains
unknown if
scp-2406-1 was ever used prior to the
destruction of scp-2406
personnel are not to attempt activation
of scp-2406-1
unless authorized by site command
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
ian j alsop
zargaron
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
savanity
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
scio dio damnares
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore drew peacock
eric corbich
longinus
james saba
and
njvojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
[Music]
you